I want you to start changing how you
think about procrastination immediately
rule number one stop labeling yourself a
procrastinator you are not a
procrastinator you have a habit of
procrastinating big difference when you
call yourself a procrastinator like I
used to it becomes part of your identity
and procrastination is not a personality
trait procrastination is a broken
pattern of behavior that you need to
understand and then you need to fix it
and replace it with something better and
you may be the kind of person right now
where procrastination is chronic in your
life that's okay that just tells me that
the stress in your life is also chronic
and so today whether you're just kind of
procrastinating on little things or
you're so stressed out because you're
constantly procrastinate on the big
things you are going to get simple tools
these simple three-step process that you
are going to use based on Research in
order to break the Vicious Cycle of
procrastination and to take back your
time and your life hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing thing that saved me as
an entrepreneur was watching the stories
of other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn the real reason why
you procrastinate and how you can
overcome it enjoy
this is big stuff and I'm going to warn
you like a lot of things that I share at
first glance it might sound kind of
stupid this one might even sound a
little smarmy but this is all research
based when you catch yourself
procrastinating
forgive yourself
step one
the next time you catch yourself
procrastinating step one
is forgive yourself
and there is a really profound reason
why
procrastination is not about laziness
it's not about a lack of discipline it's
not something you do because you're dumb
procrastination is a coping mechanism
you just have a desire to feel good
right now and you deserve that
you have a desire to lessen the stress
in your life
and you deserve to lessen the stress in
your life I get it when you're somebody
that procrastinates you're really hard
on yourselves to begin with
in fact being hard on yourself is one of
the major causes of why you're so damn
stressed and so taking a moment and
forgiving yourself and you've got to
actually have a talk with yourself where
you are sitting there like oh my God two
hours just went by wow I must be really
stressed out
I forgive myself for just blowing off
two hours on social media and you know
what I can spend the next hour setting
my day up tomorrow for success or maybe
you see all your bills and you realize
you haven't opened those suckers in two
months
just go wow I haven't opened my bills in
two months I must be really nervous
about this
I forgive myself for not doing that and
you know what I'm gonna do
I'm I'm gonna just do the best that I
can I'm going to face this head-on
because the next step that you're going
to take once you forgive yourself you
got to recognize that you're doing it
why because patterns and habits repeat
unless you replace them and so noticing
that it's a pattern catching yourself
forgiving yourself that is a way we're
going to break this pattern is the step
two based on Research you must identify
what you're stressed about I'm really
stressed about this presentation that's
coming up I'm really stressed that I'm
behind on my sales quota
I'm really stressed that my spouse and I
haven't really talked for the last
couple days and they're really mad at me
I'm really stressed about getting these
test results back from my dad
worried about him when you identify
what you're actually stressed about
it loosens its grip on you
it comes out of hiding and see I think
that stress backpack is an important
analogy or metaphor if you're sitting on
the couch two glasses of wine in and you
realize you've procrastinated for the
last five hours
and you've
acknowledged it you've forgiven yourself
for doing it you've acknowledged the
stress that you feel because you know
you are in a fight with a friend or a
boyfriend or whatever
what is the you that's going to wake up
tomorrow morning want you to do right
now I'll tell you what that you wants
you to do they want you to get off the
couch they want you to pack lunch for
tomorrow they want you to brush your
teeth and turn off the TV and the phone
and read 10 pages of non-fiction and get
a good night's sleep that's what the
future you wants you to do the future
you does not want you to slip back into
that vicious cycle and spend another
three hours watching cat videos and
memes and Tick Tock videos which we both
know is exactly what you would do if you
didn't break the cycle by forgiving
yourself for doing it for three hours
acknowledging what you're stressed about
and then deciding what the future you
wants you to do instead and then finally
use the five second rule why this is not
just listening time people this is doing
time we always say that about the Mel
Robbins podcast
use the five second rule it's one of the
most effective science-backed starting
rituals on the planet for creating a new
habit or pattern and all you're going to
do is you're just going to start
because after you've forgiven yourself
and you've validated what's stressing
you out and you've tapped into the
future you who is kicking ass and taking
names and needs you right now I just
want you to start for one minute so vidi
and that self-doubt is there and that
procrastination kicks in no problem use
the steps and then 54321
start drawing for one minute
and here's what we know based on the
research once you make that first cold
call
you're likely to keep going
once you start writing that first
sentence on this chapter you're going to
keep writing once you hit record on that
video on the video you're going to keep
going once you fill out the first name
last name line on the application you
need to fill out you're going to keep
going once you pull up your resume
template and you start writing
you're going to keep going
because the problem isn't your ability
to do what you need to do
the problem is you've been trapped in
this stress and Trauma and nervous
system triggered vicious procrastination
cycle rule number two is write down your
worries with Brendan Bouchard
procrastination basically means that you
are not doing what you know you need to
do when you know you need to do it is
putting things off because in the short
term
it's easier it's more comfortable it's
more certain it's more pleasureful to be
distracted or to indulge yourself doing
something else than it is to sit down
and do the actual work to create the
outputs that matter when they are needed
and I know that every single one of us
procrastinates me too so it's okay
the issue is can you set yourself up so
you do less of it
I believe you can most procrastination
is either tied to worry the emotion of
worry like I'm worried that if I do it
it won't turn out well
oh I'm worried it's gonna be too hard
and I can't handle it or I'm worried I
don't know what I'm really gonna do and
I'm going to mess things up fail or
cause ruin in my life so a big part if
you ever feel like you're
procrastinating sit down with a journal
and say what am I worried about
and really just Journal just write it
out like what am I worried about
well I'm I'm worried if I do this
because what happens is unconsciously
we're not aware you know we're just
we're not aware of our worries so we
keep thinking it's the task's fault well
the task is not passionate well it's not
you know we say well maybe it's not my
real passion maybe it's not my real
purpose and we start blaming ourselves
and we start having like these you know
these esoteric kind of conversations
with ourselves about life's meaning
instead what's happening is
unconsciously we're a little worried
about something
and if we can bring that worry
into our awareness
then we can examine it observe it and
start building the case that that's not
something we should be worried about or
something that is something we can truly
handle rule number three is don't feed
your mind with negativity with Marissa
peer here's the truth
everything you're doing your mind thinks
you want to do that you want to
procrastinate you want to leave
everything until the last minute you
want to put often we say things like oh
I hate studying oh I hate doing my taxes
I hate doing my paperwork I hate being
under pressure
and if your mind picks that which of
course it has no choice but to pick it
up it says oh you don't want to do that
stuff let me give you an overwhelming
urge to straighten out your drawers to
straighten the cushions because you've
told your minds I mean your mind is the
genie
and your wish is it's come out I don't
want to do that means let me delay you
let me help you procrastinate
and why would you want to delay and
procrastinate well you can go to this to
every area right you're always going to
come back to the same thing I'm scared
of failing I'm scared of not being
enough I had a book and it's been in a
draw for 10 years but I can't submit it
why not
in case nobody likes I've got an idea
for a product and I've just watched
someone take my product idea and do
really well why didn't I do that well
all roads lead to Rome every thread will
tell you to the same answers somehow I'm
scared of being rejected I'm scared of
failing I'm scared of not being enough
and it's easier to procrastinate and
never do and go you know I Coulda Woulda
Shoulda but I just couldn't get it
together that's less painful than saying
I did it it was terrible my book got all
four reviews nobody bought my product I
lost all my money we're so scared of
being rejected we're scared of failing
and that fear is so profound that it
causes us to deny ourselves
opportunities but here's the truth you
cannot fail by trying failing to try
it's the same as trying to fail if you
wrote a book and it didn't do very well
you go well that's sad but I gave it
everything I tried I realized I wasn't
meant to be a writer I found something
else that's actually better than saying
I could have always been a writer but
you know I just never finished it I just
something wrong with me
the only risk in life is not to take the
risk many people take a product to
Market it doesn't work but they bring it
back and they try again and again and
they eventually get it right we all know
the KFC story of how many recipes
Colonel Sanders had until he made it we
know how many times James Dyson worked
on a prototype to get this incredible
vacuum cleaner right we know how many
times Edison failed at creating a light
but eventually he did it
it's when you give up that you feel a
failure but when you fail at something
you get better you come back and even if
you don't you can say well I did try
that I realized it wasn't going to work
so I found a different dream I created a
different plan I realized I was going in
the wrong direction but you will never
know that
if you keep procrastinating so
understand procrastination is really two
things the fear of failure and a fear of
being rejected also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is create a dream
collage with Robin Sharma this is still
the first thing that I did to be
procrastination is you want to do a
dream collage I'm going to show you
exactly what a dream collage looks like
a dream collage is basically you open up
your journal and you get a few free
pages okay and then you take all the
images of your ideal life or your dreams
coming true and you glue them into this
uh into your Journal so you get this
collage of all these perfect things that
you want to have happen now what the
what's the primary principle it's this
the subconscious mind runs about 95
percent of your life only five percent
of your life or what you're perceiving
is um is really it it's five percent is
your conscious mind most of what's
happening in your life right now is
being run by the 95 percent that's sort
of the invisible World which is your
subconscious mind and the real key is
the subconscious mind operates through
pictures
so you want to use that to your
advantage and I've got for example I've
got architectural digest we're going to
rip out some pictures here I'll show you
exactly what I mean in a second we've
got the robber Port so let's say a lot
of people they like nice cars I've got a
picture of a Fisker here I'm going to
show you you know big house a lot of
people want a big house so I'm going to
show you exactly how to do a dream
collage so you can get this done really
quickly so you start running pictures
through your subconscious mind and
believe it or not okay once you start
training your subconscious mind to focus
on the the visual life that you want
then your performance starts to follow
because your performance is always
aligned with your subconscious mind
again only five percent is run by your
conscious mind so I want to show you the
dream collage in action you know I took
a travel and Leisure and what I did was
I took a picture of the Eiffel Tower
let's say the Eiffel Tower is one of
your places to visit you know you've got
your journal and you've actually got
your Magnificent Obsession statement and
you glue it into your journal and one
page and then let's say you're into
Yachts so I got this from I ripped out
another Magazine from another magazine
the Rob report so if you're into Yachts
let's say I mean dream big right
um you put your your picture of your
yacht in here that I took another
magazine architectural digest a lot of
people love big homes it's a you know a
meaningful goal to a lot of people and I
took out a picture of just a beautiful
modern home you know you can you can
have a look at it right there and that
goes into your dream collage literally
you paste the pictures of your ideal
life maybe it's your Fitness level maybe
it's the car you want to drive
everything goes into this dream collage
you look at it every morning when you
get up you look at it every evening when
before you go to sleep and really what
it's all about is this ever since we've
been little kids we've picked up all
these mess all of this messaging from
our parents from our teachers from our
peers from society and that literally
forms that 95 percent that we're not
conscious of so the five percent is what
we're conscious of but it's the 95
subconscious part of our brains that is
really running the show and we have all
of these fears and all these doubts and
all these messages that we've picked up
about what we can't do don't dream like
this you could never have this kind of
car or you could never run this kind of
business or you can't change the world
and literally we go through life and we
wonder why we can't make our dreams come
true and we blame it on the outer world
and we play victim but the reality is
it's our own selves we are our own
saboteurs in so many ways and this dream
collages with a Magnificent Obsession
the first way that I beat
procrastination will really help you
shatter your chains so you get big
things done rule number five is find
your why with Jim quick find your why
remember the second power question the
first question was how can I use this
the second question is why must I use
this one of my favorite books as I
mentioned is by Simon sinek start with
why head heart hands if you have a goal
in mind but you're procrastinating with
your hands check in with the second age
which is your heart get back to the
emotions because we do things not always
logically but emotionally because we're
not logical all the time but we're
always biological dopamine oxytocin
serotonin endorphins where this chemical
super feelings and emotion tap into that
reservoir of energy you can't steer
apart car you need fuel and energy so
find your why what are all the benefits
that could I'll have if I do this thing
how good will I feel on the other side
of this once this thing is done or if
it's not positive emotions use those
negative emotions to propel you forward
what's going to happen if I don't do
this who am I disappointing if I don't
get this done who's watching me right
now that's counting on me to be
successful and to show up today use
positive or negative emotions Propel you
forward that number five is to find your
why rule number six is do the important
work first with Marie forleo I have work
that pays my bills and then there's all
this other work I want to do that never
seems to get done when my clients need
me I drop everything to get that work
done because it's my job but then
everything else suffers for example I
have a Blog but I'm not consistent I
want to write a novel and I want to
volunteer but at the end of the day I
never have enough energy to get to the
things that I dream about every night
when I go to bed I always think tomorrow
will be the day that I start blank but
it never happens any ideas to help
thanks Angela Angela you are so not
alone millions of people have a secret
or not so secret unlived creative life
that feels just out of their grasp now
the good news here is that you can break
this pattern and make all of your dreams
come true so there's a lot to say on
this topic but today I want to focus on
one simple strategy that will crack this
whole thing wide open for you and I
think my friend Stephen pressfield said
it best when he said I'm keenly aware of
the principle of priority which states a
you must know the difference between
what's urgent and what's important and B
you must do what's important first
what's important is the work this is the
whole damn thing Ange this is the thing
that so many people miss and it kills
them so many things in life can feel
urgent but they're not so a few examples
checking email answering calls or texts
even from clients and social media
urgent things demand our attention now
and they can get really addictive
because we all want to feel wanted now
many of us also like a little hit of
drama and adrenaline which email and
social and tax and things like that
happily deliver and finally things that
are Urgent often relate to other
people's goals not our own but important
things are different and important
things are quiet there's no alarms
there's no drama important things often
relate to our own goals and dreams not
other people and unfortunately it
requires us to be self-starters and
important things are often easy to blow
off hey Marie are we still hanging out
today or she's busy sorry okay I'll hit
you up tomorrow see where you're at
we'll see about that
stuff to do
um the first order of business let's
check Twitter right yeah now Angela I
know you got clients to attend to and
work that pays the bills and sometimes
yes that is urgent however you do have
enough time to create your art and reach
your goals as long as you work on what's
important first and save what's urgent
for a little bit later here's how to do
this now before you get going each day I
want you to take a look at your to-do
list and you're going to Mark each task
with either an i or a u i is more
important and U is for Urgent and then
work on all the eye stuff first and save
the use stuff till later now you got to
remember the Urgent stuff is always
going to get done because it has to but
this method ensures that your important
tasks don't fall to the Wayside and
unless somebody is seriously hurt or
your house is on fire if something
urgent tries to take your attention
ignore it until your important work is
done for the day and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is remind yourself of your
mortality with Lewis
remind yourself that you are going to
die now I know this might sound a little
dark but hear me out for a minute
there's a country in South Asia called
Bhutan and it consistently ranks as one
of the happiest countries in the world
and when this information first came out
people were of course curious as to why
the bhutanese were so much happier than
other countries where their habits are
mindset or cultural practices that cause
them to have more joy than the rest of
us the answer is pretty incredible and
it stuck with me over the years one of
the main reasons Bhutan is Happy is
because every single day they make it a
cultural priority to remind themselves
that they are going to die by doing that
they naturally don't seem to sweat the
small stuff and instead focus on the
things that matter the most their loved
ones their health their community and
all the things that are valuable to them
and if you don't want to do this
exercise on your own there's also apps
like we croak that will remind you on
your phone multiple times a day that
you're gonna die literally it's an app
that just pops up and says you're gonna
die to remind you of this practice and I
think this practice is such a game
changer because it really forces you to
look at things from a higher level take
a bigger perspective on life it takes
you out of the day-to-day task that's
the source of the stress for so many of
us that bogs us down the social media
they're responding to emails the the
chores the errands the distractions the
making sure the house is clean or
getting our workout in the name it all
the distractions that make us focused on
the small things that stress us out as
opposed to the Gratitude of our life it
brings us back to the only thing that's
certain for all of us that we're all
going to leave this earth one day and
it's an important reminder so why not
make happiness a priority now not
waiting for when something happens make
it a priority right now why hold off on
writing that book or launching that
podcast or opening up that Ecommerce
store or developing the relationship you
want to have or mending a relationship
or for forgiving people whatever it
might be we only have a short amount of
time to do it and being reminded of that
consistently can help us overcome
procrastination
the single most important part in
learning to be honest with yourself is
to accept that you must have self-esteem
and the problem is most people build
their self-esteem around something
stupid so most people build their
self-esteem around being right being
good being smart being worthy and they
see all of those as permanent traits and
so anything that challenges them being
smart which is my big one oh God even to
this day if I really want to get into a
bad place I'll just go hang around
people that are just legitimately
smarter than me and then focus on how
cool being smart is now I can be around
them when I value myself for being the
learner but the second I let myself slip
into just wanting to be cool for being
smart then being around those people is
like getting kicked in the face it sucks
man and so I had this I went through
this phase in my life that I call the
king of remedial jobs phase and I wanted
so this is post Film School post like
realizing that I don't have talent
I just need to be smart man I just need
to build myself back up by being smart
and so I would apply for jobs like I
worked I sold video games retail
um and I sold Insurance door to door I
did anything that I could where I knew
that the person interviewing me at some
point during the interview was going to
say why are you applying for this job
like you're too smart for this and be
like I'm right where I need to be which
is crazy and sad but absolutely true and
so I did that for a couple years and in
that phase it was I just didn't want my
intelligence to be challenged so Flash
Forward now I'm working with these two
entrepreneurs they hire me as a
copywriter I'm in an entrepreneurial
environment for the first time and there
clearly smarter than me that that isn't
even Up For Debate and I'm
arguing with them for this idea because
I needed to win I just I couldn't take
another time where it's like they're
smarter than me they're smarter than me
so I was like all right I'm gonna win on
this idea and somewhere in the argument
I realized I was wrong and there was a
voice in my head screaming you're wrong
dude you are wrong you know you're wrong
shut up like stop pushing for this what
are you doing and I kept going and I
finally like whittled them down and they
finally just gave up and so they said
yep we'll do it your way fine whatever
and right then and there it's the one
time in my life that was truly a
lightning rod moment where my life can
be divided before and after and that
moment was realizing that I was telling
everybody that I wanted to get rich but
the way I was acting was like I just
wanted to feel smart and I thought hey
no judgment I'm totally cool whichever
it is like we can craft a life where
that would be wonderful so if what you
really want is to just be smart and to
feel smart all the time you have to quit
you've got to get out of this
environment because they make you feel
stupid all the time and that's not a
great place to be feeling badly about
yourself all the time for any reason
even if it's self-inflicted it's not a
bad scenario or it's not a good scenario
you've got to get out of it so I was
like okay so that's option one get out
of this scenario go back to being the
king of remedial jobs
or if you actually want to get rich
start acting in accordance with it start
making decisions based on that and so I
was like okay well I'm gonna have to
give up my self-esteem I'm gonna have to
like stop worrying about feeling good
about myself and I was like oh
that is clearly a losing proposition
there is no way to come in and feel
horrible every day and think that I will
have the energy to see this through so I
was like God what else could I do I was
like well I guess I could build my
self-esteem around something that is
sort of impervious to being around
people that are smarter than me and what
would that be being the learner and I
thought okay well I can choose to do
that I could choose to build my
self-esteem around being
not right but finding the right answer
not being smart but working hard to
learn and so that became just like the
core of my existence I decided in that
moment I'm going to start valuing myself
for how rapidly I can admit when I'm
wrong how much I learn how much time and
energy I put into learning and once I
switch that and I switch my identity and
my behaviors around to being the learner
then all of a sudden everything changed
and that's when I went on hockey stick
growth because all of a sudden if we
were arguing and I realized you were
right I'd be like dude he's right you're
totally right I see it oh my God thank
you so much and so I started earning a
reputation I never just backed into a
corner I never argued for something just
because it was my idea I was
legitimately on the hunt to find the
right answer and so now I'm getting the
internal feedback of hey you said that
you were going to always focus on being
the learner you're doing it you said
you'd always admit when you're wrong and
I would try to shorten that timeline
down so I wasn't like taking an hour to
finally admit it or even three minutes
that I was trying to get to it like dude
if I realized I was wrong three seconds
it's 30 seconds Max like I'm you know
just finally saying it look you're
totally right I'm with you yep I see it
and then the world was like whoa working
with this guy is awesome he's not trying
to take credit for other people's ideas
he will change on what he was saying in
a heartbeat when he you know he fights
for what he believes in but the second
you can convince him he's convinced and
then he moves on and it just became a
really awesome environment so that was
hugely transformative but it forces you
to constantly be on the lookout for
where am I wrong I'm gonna take
everybody back four years ago so this is
the first book the high five habit is
the first book that I have written and
published in almost five years
back in 2007 I released a book called
the five second rule
and Lisa and her husband Tom played a
pivotal role in one of the biggest
professional breakdowns of my life and
they had no idea that it was happening
at the time no clue and Lisa I think you
just found out about it by reading about
it in chapter 12 of my new book yep so
here's what was going on I had written
the five second rule book I had
self-published it because I thought that
that was the best thing to do I had a
dream of being a number one New York
Times best-selling author and I put it
up on my vision board and I dreamed
about it and I thought about it and I
studied all the authors that we all
admire and I did my best to do all the
things that you uh are supposed to do in
order to sell enough books to Grace the
New York Times bestseller list right so
I email my newsletter list and I am due
doing speeches all over the place and
I'm pre-selling books as best I can in
the back of a room with my pad of paper
taking people's like literally for
months I did everything I could
and when the book came out
I sent the email out to everybody
and folks on my email list and everybody
I'm related to immediately went to
Amazon to buy the book
and here's what happened within an hour
or two the book was listed as out of
stock now I thought yes yes I have won I
am a best-selling author I have sold out
of Amazon in a matter of a few hours oh
my God oh my God this like literally
this this proves all the things that
everybody said about me in middle school
is not true anymore I I've done it Lisa
and then I started to realize I had not
sold all the books because I did not
have I had 20 000 books at Amazon I did
not have that many people on my email
list and people started to email back
going it's out of stock it's out of
stock do you think you'll dream like the
height of your freaking dreams come true
yes I think I've done it like I've so
like I am a success I am a phenomenon
this is unbelievable I think the dreams
are coming true and then within a couple
hours people start emailing going it's
out of stock now it's out of stock it's
out of stock it's out of stock
it Dawns on me there's no way I sold 20
000 books there's nothing why
I call the printer that I worked with
that helped me self-publish and you know
it's a little self-publishing publisher
and he tells me that he's seen this
happen before where when Amazon gets a
flood of traffic to something that
they're not expecting
they will turn off Supply
to make sure it's not a bunch of bots
and to also check inventory
and we had no ability
to figure this out so for the first
couple weeks that the book was available
it was out of stock so here I am
in this two-week period
where I have worked my ass off I have
done everything you're supposed to do
Lisa and my book is out of stock
I have sent my entire marketing campaign
to a product you can't get and I'm
thinking why are you doing this to me
Universe I have worked hard why do I
have to be the Bad News Bears why am I
not part of that super like awesome
group of best-selling authors one is it
going to be my turn and I start to go
down the drain
enter
Tom and Lisa Villa so when I come here
and I am doing your show
I show up here and I'm like this is my
last hope Because by the time this thing
gets on air maybe the book will be
available I have got to pull myself
together so I walk in here and I was
just I I didn't know you yet because I
only knew like impact Theory and I've
only seen it I knew this was a big deal
I knew that being on Tom's show could
really like change things for me and I
walk in here and I feel like a complete
failure you are lovely and delightful
and I immediately start feeling like I
don't freaking belong here I mean they
just had this best-selling author and
that best-selling offer and this famous
person was just here what am I doing
here I am a self-published author with a
book that's out of stock like I'm I'm
failing I hope that they don't know
because this is terrible like he is
going to figure out before I enter the
set that I don't belong here you think
imposter syndrome Galore oh completely
so I'm upstairs in the bathroom and I am
having a case no kidding a stress
diarrhea like I have got to empty the
bowels because I am so sure that I'm
about to be called out for the fraud
that I am that the book is not
successful that Tom's made a mistake I
look at the mirror my cheeks are as red
as a baboon's ass I am sweating
profusely I've got pit stains on my red
shirt and then there's a knock on the
door we're ready for you Mel
I splash water on my face
I literally am like
54321 like pull your together Mel
get the out there and I open up the
door and I go and walk out there and do
it anyway
that's what you've got to develop in
life and that moment taught me that and
there was something else that happened
so when I left that set
the whole time that the book was out of
stock and I'm sitting here going woe is
me and I've failed again and I screw
everything up and why doesn't anything
ever work out for me I would catch
myself
and I would say this there's no way Mel
that you've worked this hard
that something amazing isn't going to
happen
you have to keep going you have to
believe that this moment is preparing
you for something amazing that hasn't
happened yet
that was the Mantra that had deep
meaning for me in this moment because it
was a way for me to take an attitude
that was going down the toilet
and flip it into what I call a high five
attitude that was more empowering and
supportive and encouraging and so I kept
repeating it Lisa many of us have issues
with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start I found personally
being in business for myself for the
last 20 years that I have been a little
overly productive I almost did too much
and I was constantly multitasking and
making things happen and just moving so
fast that ultimately I really burnt out
and I started feeling brain fog I was
feeling disoriented I couldn't focus I
was feeling like even though I for so
many years was priding myself on the
fact that I could get so much done at
one time I actually don't think I was
being nearly as productive as I could
have been so I hit a bottom recently
with this productivity overload and I
realized that I had to change my
patterns I had to change my ways I was
then blessed I said a prayer I said I
need some help with my brain fog and I
need some help with my productivity
issue and I that day got an email from
The Dr Oz Show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
doctor Dr Mike Dow and me and Mike had
been in touch many years for many years
just because he had been an author we
were published by the same Publishers
and Mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day I'm like thank you
Universe you're giving me exactly what I
need I go on Dr Oz with Mike and I'm
backstage with him and I'm like listen
I'm feeling so chaotic and I'm
multitasking so much and my I feel like
I've got brain fog and I'm forgetting
things and he looked at me and says how
much are you doing at one time and I
said oh Mike I'm doing a million things
at once I have a thousand tabs up on my
screen and he's like these are Big Brain
no-nos and they're also productivity
no-nos is what he said because he said
that the more I try to do and the more I
try to multitask the less I'm actually
getting done so he gave me a tip that I
want to share with you that has changed
everything for me and his suggestion was
to just do five things a day to make a
list of the five most important things
that I need to do that day and not do
number two until I've completed number
one and then once I complete number one
move on to number two then on to number
three and if I don't get through all
five in one day I'll just pick up the
fifth the next day or wherever I left
off I'll pick up the next day and to
really stick to that list and not move
back and forth and not try to make a
million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
I did it I started to just be very clear
about the five things I was doing in a
day I told my team I made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and I made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
I'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that I was only
going to do five things I have been more
productive I have created more I have
been more intuitive I have been more
inspired and I've been more creative so
I I've had such success doing less and
back in the day what I would have done
two weeks ago before I started doing
this practice I would have tried to do
30 things in a day not really completing
any one of them and feeling completely
stressed out and and not on top of
anything not complete in any area so as
a result of making the commitment to
five things a day I have completely
changed how productive I am by doing
less so I give you this as an
opportunity to be less stressed out to
get more done to be more creative to
take a little bit off your plate and to
try to really be complete a task before
you move on to the next one ladies I
know that you are much like me those
multitasking ladies out there and you
probably have a million browsers up stop
it bring down those browsers be more
conscious and be more mindful of the
ways that you show up for your
productivity and the less you do the
more you will create I was a
maybe 24 25 year old man and I was a
member of Kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know Kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or Lions Club
um it's a it's a a it's a non-profit
organization that's dedicated towards
servicing in the community and I was in
Kiwanis and I was the youngest one hands
down like in in the room we get together
every single month on a Tuesday and we
have lunch and we'd have a speaker in
and then we talk about a volunteer
project we were going to do that month
and that was kind of how it went in
Kiwanis for me and so I but in my room I
was 24 25 in the room every Tuesday when
we got together everyone else was older
I mean they were like 50s and 60s and
70s older when I was 25 I was the
youngest person in the room every single
time and
I remember I was having a particularly
a challenging time because I was
thinking about quitting my job but I was
scared because I didn't I hadn't saved
any money
um I didn't know exactly what I want to
do I just knew that I I knew that the
job wasn't the thing at the time
but I didn't know what it was and so I
was scared to make the leap and I was
just I was just kind of struggling with
some existential stuff because you know
I'd been four or five years I hadn't had
a girlfriend and it was just frustrating
I was like dating but I wasn't able I
just wasn't making real connections on
when I was dating and I was just unhappy
in that part of my life I didn't know
what I was doing my career I didn't have
a significant relationship I was like oh
man I'm just kind of I didn't feel good
and so I was having a really down day
on that particular Tuesday and I went in
and I was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the Just One of the
awesome kiwanians that who was there and
he was
um I think he was probably 59 60 years
old he was in banking
um very successful wealthy guy happy hap
just he was like a happy-go-lucky
Grandpa type you know just a good dude
and I'm just kind of listing off to him
all these things that suck you know and
he says what are you doing about it and
I said well you know I you know and he
says well I bet and he said I bet I know
what's going on he's you're going home
you're probably watching too much TV
drinking too much beer and sitting alone
too often or you're going out and not
having any fun and we're just talking my
mode was yeah I kind of I go inside so I
kind of pull away from people when I'm
unhappy and so I was like yeah I kind of
pull away and I'm in my house and he
says why I know how to solve a problem
I said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
buy tickets what do you buy tickets he
goes I want you to open up the paper
remember the papers so he's I want you
to open up the paper and he goes I want
you to see what's going on in your town
and I want you to buy tickets to
whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends is it is there a symphony
coming to town buy tickets is there a
ballet buy tickets is there a uh an art
museum buy tickets is there he said is
there a concert buy tickets
and I said what do you mean as buy
tickets I want you to buy one two three
four tickets and I want you to take your
friends and I just want you to go I want
you to buy tickets and I want you to go
and I'm like what the hell does this
have to do with anything I'm even
talking about he goes just buy the
tickets and come back next month tell me
about the tickets I'm like no and he
literally pulls out his wallet and I'll
never forget he sets down three 100
dollar bills and he goes
buy the tickets here's the money and I'm
like what are you even I was literally
so frustrated it's a long story short
I'll try to keep it shorter but so I
bought tickets I got like a symphony
ticket I uh got it there was like a
dance troupe in town or something weird
um there's a Dave Matthews concert
and what else there's one other thing I
can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets I
went with one or two or three friends
and
went to them and the second I remember
even I remember the opening act for the
Dave Matthews Band started and I was
like
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so I was down and out and he got me
out and about and then with you with
your friends and you're socializing and
it's in a new environment and things are
happening and my mind just started
turning on again I started getting all
these ideas and these dreams that I
don't know where they were they weren't
in my room they weren't in my bed these
ideas and dreams they weren't happening
in my journal the the the ideas and
dreams they weren't happening in my my
daily planner it was like I was stuck
there so he moved me over here have you
ever been like at a ballet or a symphony
in Orchestra and you're just sitting
there and all of a sudden you feel
amazing
like the music hits you this idea comes
in and you walk out and you feel amazing
have you ever gone to a Broadway show
you went in and you were frustrated and
freaked out because all the horrible New
York traffic and all of a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
Broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now no problem is
gonna slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to seminar buy tickets to
the event buy tickets to the art museum
the ballet buy tickets and I mean if
you're down and out and your life sucks
right now go buy tickets for the next
four weeks and I promise you're gonna be
like damn buy tickets that changed my
life
changed my life too and I've learned
ever since then like if I'm down and out
it's like buy tickets it dawned on me
that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
uh may be exciting and may release
dopamine the neurochemical that he knows
the reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain
whether it's starting to exercise or
eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
the very nature of how our brain works
is that patterns that have been repeated
over you know months and years are the
dominant patterns in our brain and
therefore it's easier for our brain to
activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there's certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results I think one of my
first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast
which they know all the time we're
saying all the time but if I don't hear
a no from the guest directly that's not
a no like someone's team can say no
someone's assistant can say no someone's
PR team can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah how do you
deal with that type of so I've had you
say this I've said a couple of times and
I'm sure it's been repeated a bunch of
times around how I genuinely believe
failure has feedback feedback and and so
for me it's like failure has the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah and I think a lot of people can do
that in life but we're so afraid to like
go on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact in the grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline
this is a lack of follow-through it's
the constant start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reason why I'm here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post to my
socials of how I grew month over month
year over year on YouTube and in the
first five years I had seven thousand
subscribers or so
five years in five years in of making
content
seven thousand subscribers a lot of you
already ahead of that a lot of you could
get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had to discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
in 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and insecure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
belief all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me
I remember sitting down at a
Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my mystery it was in
music I'm gonna be the next garyvee in
music and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
it let's me you know let's let's keep in
touch and see how we do and how we grow
and he posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the host and I told him I was
gonna be the next garyvee for music and
he's gonna do keep doing his thing and
and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's a
super talented in music and just better
camera presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff
all of it
the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the lack of because you're
not motivated you stop and lack of
motivation isn't a good enough reason
you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you uh how do you stay disciplined how
do you stay focused when you're not
getting results when you're not seeing
the wins how do you stay disciplined
okay so let me give you a couple things
first is having a really powerful
morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day no
matter how great today is tomorrow's a
new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event or you
watch a video get all inspired and you
expect it to last and then tomorrow you
wake up it's like oh how come I don't
feel the same way as I did yesterday and
then that creates this cycle of
procrastination instead of actually
following through so the morning routine
really matters what is it that gets you
feel inspired motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off
and have a much better day for me
two of the things that I find the most
valuable are in my morning routine one
is music so I put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your
state put on songs that make you move
that make you dance and make you wanna
just change your state because you wake
up tired and no energy like let's go we
gotta demand Excellence from ourselves
and so music is the fastest way to get
your body into a different state
um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day I walk I go
to Tim Hortons I grab a cup of coffee
and spend you know two bucks on it and I
think about my day how do I want my day
to go what how do I want to be
intentional about the day so we're not
waking up like an accident most people
wake up like an accident fall into their
day look at other people you load your
phone right other people's agenda for
your time and then you don't follow
through and so having that as part of my
morning routine really helps me so what
is your morning routine the most
important thing that you need to do is
the thing that makes you feel important
vibrant that today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happened
that's why I make so many videos too
there's content for you every day if you
need me in your life or you need the
people that I profoundly there's
something every single day for you
across my channels so there's no excuse
for you not to get the the inspiration
and the motivation and the tactics that
you need to make your dreams happen so
that's step number one is have have a
powerful morning routine step number two
is create a calendar you know what's in
your calendar I'm making videos today
because it's in my calendar today's a
Tuesday when I'm recording this and
Tuesday is my YouTube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening in
my business uh you know right now we're
at um my my wife's parents house and
they're delivering a couch
see that they're delivering a couch here
it's a delivering a couch and they're
helping I'm here making content because
Tuesday is my YouTube day you know
there's so many other things I could be
doing right now
if I was left to my own devices I'd say
I have something more important to do I
need to be doing X
but because this has been scheduled in
my calendar I'm going to follow through
and make videos
how have I made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do I'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later I'm still afraid to make
videos why because I want these videos
to be the best I've ever done because I
want to show up with more care more
heart more passion I hope that this is a
video that forces you you know to take
some kind of action I wanted to be the
best one that I've done and so I I'm
mini procrastinate before making videos
on a Tuesday every week I have a mini
mini procrastination the only difference
is my procrastination is you know 10
minutes instead of days 10 days and then
it doesn't happen right and so whatever
you are procrastinating on that you know
is important that you're just afraid of
you put it in your calendar and you
block off time and that allows you the
creativity and the space and suffocates
the excuses
for you not to follow through and then
step number three so one have a morning
routine right that sets you up it
creates that gets you inspired makes you
feel like you're important today is
going to matter two you create a
schedule for when you're gonna do the
things especially the scary things on
your list and then three you have to
teach yourself that you do the things
that are in your calendar
you said you're gonna do it you put in
your calendar you get it done even if
you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow or you can change your
calendar for next week
but don't trust yourself or listen to
yourself when you're feeling low when
you're feeling overwhelmed and you said
you're gonna do it
you have to go up and do it to teach
yourself because what happens is the
next time you say you're going to do
something you put in your calendar you
don't trust it you're going to follow
through because you haven't followed
through the last 20 times
so be very careful about what you put
into your calendar and when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline again you've got the heart
you've got the creativity you've got the
passion you've got the willingness to
serve you know you can do more you want
to create an amazing life for yourself
your family the people around you like
you know you've got this thing is you
know you've got this thing I don't need
to tell you this you know that you've
got something amazing inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough you have to stop jumping from
high to high to high and and wondering
why you don't feel motivated today
there's nothing wrong with you this is
normal
discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want the eight steps to destroy laziness
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there what we do is we
kind of check out because it feels
overwhelming or we check out because
we're afraid or we check out because we
start listening to self-doubt and then
we make these teeny tiny decisions all
day long